Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P. I got a call. This
is pretty interesting. There's a caller who
isn't happy with an anti-death penalty argument
that I guess I made at some point. Take a
listen to this. This is very interesting.
Speaker 2: David. You did it again on
this on today's show, the death penalty
arguing that we sometimes kill the wrong people
is not an argument against the death penalty,
dude. That's an argument against the judicial
judicial system. That is not an argument against
the death penalty, just like I've heard you
say. It actually cost more to administer the
death penalty than it does to keep somebody
alive. Okay. That's an argument against, like,
government bureaucracy. That is not an argument
against the death penalty. Please state a good
argument against the death penalty, a moral one.
Speaker 1: Okay. So the claim that the caller is
making is that me being against the death penalty
in part because we execute innocent people isn't
a good argument against the morality of the death
penalty. It's an argument just against government
being unable to decide for sure, to know for sure
whether someone is actually guilty. I actually
disagree with this caller. I think all of these
are valid arguments against the death penalty.
Some want to restrict arguments against the
death penalty only to why it's wrong to have it,
assuming we could execute it perfectly. But
the reality is we live in the real world,
and so we have to be able to
consider these other arguments. So
the main argument for me being against the death
penalty is that I believe it is wrong for the
government to put people to death. I believe it
is wrong for the government or the state to say,
well, you killed someone, so now we kill you. I
think it's beneath us. I think it's retrograde.
I think it's antiquated. I think it's cruel and
unusual. So that's the main reason I'm against
the death penalty. It shouldn't be the business
of the government to be putting people to death.
In addition to that, we also have to
consider the justice system isn't perfect and
we never know. In all cases, we I can't imagine
we would ever be at 100% only guilty people
get convicted. And so that's another reason
because it is irreversible, the death penalty
is irreversible. And we want to maintain because
any justice system sometimes makes makes mistakes.
I would rather be able to release someone from
a life sentence. If they didn't really do it,
then kill them. In addition, there's the fiscal
conservatism argument where it costs more
to put someone on death row and ultimately carry
out the execution. So if you care about that,
that's also an argument we all. So all of these
things are valid arguments by itself. I agree.
Saying the death penalty should be abolished
because sometimes we kill innocent people.
I'm with you. By itself, that's not a strong
enough argument. But it's fine to include it as
part of a bigger picture about the death penalty
and its problems. And there's other issues as
well, which I brought up in the past about the
death penalty. So I respectfully disagree with
the caller that it's not a valid component of
opposition to the death penalty, but by itself,
it is not nearly strong enough. Let me know your
thoughts. We have a great bonus show for you
today. The bill to codify abortion protections has
failed in the Senate. The baby formula shortage is
making many parents very anxious. And we will
talk about Thailand's new plan to remember
Trump calls it theland. I call it Thailand
to give away a million free cannabis plants
to households. What are they up to and why? All
of those stories and more on today's bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money. Everybody else that makes money
to fund themselves is back.
Speaker 1: I'll see you then.